can we give some flowers to uh  to burner man yeah that's my dog bro i  think i have a big burn  uh doesn't get enough love when it comes  to just like  yeah that mother man he is he's built  he's built a lot  that's the thing i think i think burner  actually does get enough love he's just  so he's just like the real goat like  when you're really the goat  you don't really see you're here or  anything like that but he's always  putting in work and all the bosses go  through burn  like i just seen a video with rick ross  on burner's  cookie tour bus you know walking him  around his dispensary that he just  opened in vegas  yeah you think what i'm saying it's like  and shout out to rick ross because he's  a boss but  burner's not no little [ __ ] you feel me  and that's like you said the reason why  he gets his fliers